- Growing up so poor
is why I realized education is important.
(uplifting piano music)
My parents came from the old country
where my father only had
a second grade education,
my mom had a kindergarten.
So, it was never really embedded in us
that education is, especially for a girl,
was that important.
It was more about survival.
My mom was arranged
marriage when she was young
so already in her head,
I was gonna be arranged at the age of 16,
get married.
And who do I marry?
Another person who owns
a Chinese restaurant.
And sure enough at the age of 16,
I had met my future husband
who owned a restaurant in Long Island.
I told my mom and dad, no way.
I want to go to college.
And it never even dawned on them
that Heather should go to college.
And we came to a crossroad
where the lease at the restaurant was up.
It was at that time when all
my brothers stood up for me
and said mom and dad,
I think let's just give up the restaurant.
We all got to do what we got to do
and let Heather go to college.
It was hard because I didn't
have anybody to help me.
I only applied to three school.
I only applied to Rutgers, Cornell,
and like a safety school.
I wrote my Cornell undergrad in pencil,
my application.
I didn't even know to apply in pen.
I got into Rutgers.
When I got there I didn't
know about financial aid.
So how did I pay for my
first year of college?
All my savings since from working
since was seven years old
in a Chinese restaurant.
It was then that I met
my college roommates
and they said, "You paid?
"You could get financial aid."
Then people start helping me.
When I was Taiwan when
I was 17 and visiting
there was a earthquake.
I saw the air conditioning
fell on somebody's head.
I just tilted his head
so that he could breathe
and I was screaming for help.
It was then that I said
I wanted to help people.
My mom once says, "I wish
Heather would have been a boy,
"then I could brag about her."
Yeah.
Even throughout would I
want to go to grad school,
my mom was still saying, "Why?
"Just get married, have kids.
"That's what you're supposed to be doing."
Whereas my dad finally dawned on him
like oh, wow, she actually
could be doing something.
And gave me $10,000 to go to grad school.
My brother's daughter,
I'm really proud of her.
She went to Upenn.
I give kudos to her,
she's the first one to graduate
Ivy League in the family.
Oh but,
but it's all because of me.
When she was 12,
I was the one that said
no one ever mentored me
but from day one,
every time it was you're
gonna go to college,
you're gonna go to college,
you're going to college.
If you need any help,
I'll pay for it, yada, yada, yada, yada.
So that gives them the
confident and support
that they knew they could have.
They're quite amazed on how our life,
even my brother,
because whatever happened to me
is also happens to them.
So they really proud.
And of course having my undergrad
opened the door for me
to go to grad school
which led me to become
the physician assistant
that I am today.
If you want to go to college you should,
you should go to college.
Go for it!
(squeaking)